[Música]
volvemos a Turquía y Siria que luchan
por rescatar sobrevivientes entre las
montañas de escombro después del
terremoto de 7,8 que sacudió los países
la perspectiva es de cinco mil muertos
confirmados y posiblemente miles más
atrapados bajo edificaciones destruidas
por eso vamos a conversar sobre los
esfuerzos a los que se suman diversos
gobiernos para ello nos acompaña a hakan
el expresidente de médicos del mundo en
Turquía y está en antacae antakaya
Turquía bienvenido Gracias por estar en
France 24 sabemos que la comunicación es
muy difícil en este momento así que
bueno Quiero preguntarle primero lo
esencial Cómo son las condiciones del
terreno Y qué podemos esperar para los
próximos días
Hola buenas soy yo estoy en adana por
ahora que es una ciudad también que fue
tocada que entre estamos a dos horas por
carretera de ansia Pero tenemos equipos
ahí en antakya es una ciudad donde el
mundo está activo desde la guerra
desde que empezó la guerra en Siria así
que tenemos
más de 30 personas ahí Tenemos también
clínicas en it y en fin en la localidad
de ginderest en la parte Siria acá en
qué consiste su trabajo A partir de este
desastre natural
nosotros lo que estamos haciendo desde
que empecé la guerra por supuesto es
trabajar con los refugiados en Turquía
también con los disfrazados dentro de
Siria en una zona que cubre más de 4
millones de desplazados dentro de Siria
que
Y a fin y tenemos clínicas donde
damos servicios de
servicios de salud primario y ahora en
cinderes nuestra clínica fue también
tocada y estamos intentando limpiar y
tener acceso a la clínica para seguir
dando servicios a la gente mire uno Lee
en los titulares que Siria ya estaba
colada antes de que esto sucediera por
la guerra y que ahora se necesita mucho
más ayuda humanitaria y de manera masiva
pero pero no se alcanza uno a imaginar
Cuál es la situación real allá usted que
nos puede decir
Mira nosotros tenemos equipos en
nuestros equipos pasaban de todos los
días para abrir las clínicas y trabajar
y volver a Turquía así que tenemos un un
conocimiento de lo que está pasando en
Siria Y estos últimos años Es verdad que
la asistencia humanitaria y financiera
ha bajado mucho y la situación en Siria
solo va por peor y con el terremoto Pues
eso no va a ayudar nada asociación es
terrible pero es también muy difícil de
tener información que está correcta como
lo tenemos en Turquía o que información
que que se puede fiar Digo yo pero la
situación es muy mala Bueno
usted diría que la situación o el estado
de las estructuras en Siria después del
conflicto armado pues tiene que ver con
el alto número de fallecimientos y
además de eso pues cuéntenos usted cómo
ve el proceso para rescatar personas
bajo los escombros cuánto tiempo queda
bueno el tiempo es algo algo que se va
volando no así que cada segundo cada
minuto que pasa es puede ser que es una
vida menos y y en Turquía lo que está
pasando es con las repeticiones del
terremoto después del primero Pues es
que son complicados mucho las
intervenciones los equipos que están ahí
en los escombros Pues están Están
salir cuando hay after shows cuando hay
repeticiones y Y por supuesto eso
también
no ayuda en el sentido de que el impacto
es que no podemos a salir a la gente que
no se pueden quedar ahí
tres días
hay que sacarlos el más antes posible
también el tiempo está muy mal está
lloviendo hace frío Está nevando y
la verdad que tenemos todo ahí que va
contra de con contra de todo tipo de
intervención qué temperaturas están
teniendo en estos días allá
están variando de cinco a menos seis
grados
ahora ustedes en estos primeros días Por
supuesto creo están atendiendo a las
personas que son sacadas de la zona de
desastre pero con el pasar de los días
su labor va a empezar a aumentar y ya va
a tener más que ver además con crisis
sanitaria y bueno con otros temas que
quisiera que por favor nos contara para
France 24
por ahora no estamos organizando la
solidaridad internacional y la ayuda
internacional es muy importante aquí las
instituciones turcas están muy muy bien
organizadas tienen mucha experiencia es
un país que ha vivido muchos terremotos
y tienen también los medios y pero lo
que pasa es que la logística es la
logística con cuando el aeropuerto no se
puede utilizar cuando las carreteras no
te dejan tener acceso
a las zonas afectadas a la ciudad pues
complica complicar la internación de
rescate pero están las cosas
organizándose nosotros ahora la tarea
más importante que tenemos es dar
soporte a los centros médicos porque
fueron también tocados hay que hay que
ver de qué forma nos vamos a organizar
para poder seguir dando servicios de
a la población
mire la Organización Mundial de la Salud
se ha pronunciado dice que le preocupa
las que Llama a unas zonas silenciosas
de Turquía teniendo en cuenta todo lo
que usted nos cuenta de las condiciones
del terreno hay muchas zonas que están
aisladas o de las que no se sabe aún
nada Cómo es la situación en ese
respecto
yo de lo que sepa no hay zonas que no
sabemos nada porque porque Turquía bueno
es que como lo está diciendo es que
tienen lo lo tienen los medios para
poder para poder tener una imagen de lo
que está pasando en donde pero
es la logística es lo que estoy diciendo
sin el tiempo también imaginarse que no
podíamos volar desde hasta Estambul
desde Estambul no podíamos salir por el
mal tiempo este así que hemos aterrizado
a Dana otros han aterrizado a otras
ciudades y de ahí había que ir por la
carretera nosotros tenemos equipos que
han salido desde izmir en coche pero que
se han quedado Atrapado también por la
nieve en la carretera
es complicado pero pero ahí no hay una
mapa de de donde donde qué está pasando
Y dónde eso es accesible
bien y ya para finalizar Le quiero
preguntar humanamente usted qué
considera que es lo más importante que
debemos destacar en este momento con
esta labor de informar lo que está
sucediendo en Turquía y de canalizar
hacia allá toda la ayuda posible
normalmente
las cosas más bonita que estamos viendo
es la solidaridad internacional también
la solidaridad de dentro del país donde
la gente se movilizaron ahí hay familias
de recogida que están intentando recoger
a la gente pero estamos hablando solo de
ataque a por ahora pero hay 10 otras
regiones que están tocadas la más
importante de sandalia Pero hay más de
10 lecciones que están tocadas Y de
verdad que más que todo es la
solidaridad que se ha formado para
intentar ayudar a los que han podido
escapar y y el resto enfocarse a salvar
las vidas que siguen ahí
abajo de los escombros de los edificios
en todas las ciudades